[Musique]
ça veut dire quoi ce réseau c'est le
plus grand qu'on crée des réseaux
sociaux
logan ténue l'acheta gacon le monde
entier et rumba au congrès pour baiser
est-ce que c'est comme un flirt le même
à dix on voulait que tu viens aussi avec
nous mais il faut prendre un avion
blanquer ventre drogue et l'alcool leur
transport picards ont patrouillé toute
autre compagnie aérienne nous sommes
toujours très surpris que vous ayez
choisi un autre pays et mettre votre
téléphone en mode avion préfère crever
plutôt que d'étendre mon portable
[Applaudissements]
des fois ce [ __ ] de bordel c'est leur
foutue cas les fans
qu'est ce qu'on fait
peut-être que quelqu'un a un plan
les litanies tranquille mais si un peu
d'accord
j'y arriverai
vous n'êtes pas un terroriste en moi
ensuite unsa respecter des réseaux
sociaux
mini conférences réseaux sociaux
passe-moi patent de sa vie
[Musique]
tu sais que moi et pour piloter à 767
[Applaudissements]
atos prophète
un cap
quoi qu'il arrive que jamais ne s'est
pas bâtie pour y arriver
post que ce soit clair elle a vomi et
petits commerces des victimes tuées car
personne d'autre ne pourra y arriver
mieux que moi
[Musique]